servus kids und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video heute spieler wieder
eine zuschauer channel und zwar von
michael jank oder schreibt die first try
challenge du musst versuchen das modul
first ride zu machen wenn du es nicht
schaffst das will ich jetzt an diesen
modulen nicht nutzen wir springen jetzt
die runde rein und gucken was geht
er hat auch noch viel glück am ende
gewünscht das hab ich nicht vorgelesen
aber jetzt satt konzentration ich finde
das eine sehr gute idee eine first rage
engine jumping zu machen weil man
vielleicht am anfang ein bisschen mehr
first class macht also die module er im
ersten versuch schaffte am ende wird
natürlich ein bisschen schwieriger okay
und wir machen das jetzt so ja nehmen
jetzt die alten teehaus packen die hier
schön in die obere inventar leistet er
genau wissen welche items herausgenommen
haben wenn später alt und aus mehreren
kisten haben und gehen hier vor alles
klar
so jetzt haben wir das mal gerufen first
haben es beim ersten versuch geschafft
und können jetzt hier die items behalten
dürfte anziehen und damit sich
verwirrung kommt packen wir das hier
unten alles schön sauber rein
das modul sagt okay alles klar gute idee
ich muss schon sagen dass es bisschen
tricky er von diesem thread auf den
eisblock zu kommen das ist überraschend
schwierig für diese module okay es
geschafft aber leider nicht försterei
heißt die kiste müssen liegen lassen so
und jetzt probieren wir weiter unser
gefühl ich werde jetzt erstmal alles
wieder okay und wir nehmen wir die teams
raus zack zack zack nicht schön an die
obere leiste rein wenn wir genau wissen
welche das sind die nachrichten anderer
bringen und hier alles wird alles sauber
wie david wir wollen nicht schön ruhig
spielen
natürlich werden auch versuchen die
dinge wie zu finishen ob die check point
erreicht deswegen zu mir das ganze mal
an panpharma und die items packen wir
hier unten 1 meter damit wir nicht
verwechseln mit denen die wir nachher
laden tun sehr gut
oli jou jye alles klar alter wie blöde
drauf akmal existenz krieg moment im
leben in dem fall einfach nicht genug
ist gut die kiste liegen lassen
ich steigere mich da schon wieder so
weit
jetzt ist auch schon den live stream
gesprochen kennt ihr das wenn ihr so tut
als wird werde ich irgendwie traurig
oder so und wenn ihr euch dazu sehr
anstrengend oder zu sehr in diese
traurigkeit rein versetzt dann kommen
euch auf einmal wirklich gedreht
kennt ihr das so ok zack alles klar noch
first try noch first try alles für
strike die items raus und in die obere
leiste zack zack zack gut den goldhelm
na egal die nehmer trotzdem mit sechs
treffern
dann fühlen wir uns sicher einfach mal
bei mir dabei so ok gut dass es jetzt
förstereien und das mit first trials und
das ist okay davon deckel vom kopf und
die alles hat geklappt gut jetzt kann
man das hier so zweimal nicht sagt zack
zack zack wer weise so eine art kleine
temporäre ablagen für die items die wird
zwar schon haben aber von dem wir noch
nicht wissen ob er sie behalten dürfen
und das machen wir auch genau so okay so
gut aus gold harnisch chain hellem stein
schwert hätte ich sehr gerne jetzt bitte
kein job machen
okay okay okay okay okay und checkpoint
alles klar sagt weg damit
das braucht man nicht und wir tauschen
unsere schwerter aus nächste kiste dies
hier direkt am anfang alles klar
ich nehme auch einfach mal die eisen
axel stein achsen mit obwohl wir von
stein schwer haben das profane kanal für
mich um wieder nach
ok jetzt hier keinen job hat okay alles
da wir können es direkt wegschmeißen
das natürlich schmerzhaft leiter lars
einer sau flottgemacht schneider bei 96
prozent
dort fragte ich sie das jetzt erst gibt
weil ich noch eine geschichte erzählen
darüber wie wenig reallife ich gerade
habe
weil ich bei audi sport und youtube mich
ganz schön vor dem 100 ob er dafür
bleibt wahrscheinlich gar keine zeit
mehr
es sei denn im deathmatch ein bisschen
nackte zwei kisten beim modul 8
da kommt die kiste ziemlich spät ist die
frage kommen wir da noch hin
soweit alles gut
auf jeden fall ist es die leute ich
studiert nebenbei noch ne also die
allermeisten youtuber jetzt nicht in
meiner größenordnung aber so die es gibt
viele viele youtuber diesmal nicht zu
dem youtube machen so zum beispiel wie
nie gehört mittlerweile dazu natürlich
die allermeisten großen aber ich gehöre
noch zu denen die noch neben youtube was
machen und ich studiere konkret okay ist
es ein ziel wo die andere auch okay kein
bisschen
ja aber ich hab's geschafft okay zack
heißt noch mal alle längst und wir haben
acht gold das braucht man nicht dass sie
damit
und unser büro sie haben unser brot für
uns genommen hat das war so eine
richtige gollum aussage jetzt gucken wie
weit schafft meist aber direkt hinter
uns
rockig mal gegenseitig jungs team nicht
alles da jetzt hier wie sie erstmal
abstauben ja wolf beide kist beide teams
jetzt natürlich die kleine riesin nutzen
wir jetzt hier zu boxen hat ein
schlechtes equipment auf jeden fall
schlechte waffe und wer noch sauber hier
kommt der nächste alex grund jetzt
geht's rund
ich habe halt keine eigene das ist ein
bisschen seltsam für mich weil ich nicht
immer mit einem kämpfer und wir haben
dann den ok was jetzt was jetzt wichtig
ist da haben wir fehler gemacht in
diesem modul ich sag nein ich sage wir
haben in diesem modul das match gerade
kein job für gemacht ok zack zack zack
zack
und was braucht man noch gold futures
verfahren sie bruder auskommen oder
rotiert er nicht alter schwede
okay das ist der typische findet hat
aber keine falle
okay geben einen guten jetzt können es
theoretisch können wir zum fms kräften
ich weiß es nicht es richtig hektisch
ventspils gesamten sich sagen aber es
gibt grund so kurz mal sortieren
arm ist alter bin ich raus kommen wir
brauchen auch nach wie vor ein crafting
table dann kommen und einen golf für
machen
okay ich mache mir erstmal ein ns hier
ich sag dir immer leute das in fns auf
maps auf denen es wenig wasser gibt am
stärksten ist faul im staate stein steht
alles klar
mist war oder ob jemand wohnt als da
sind einfach weizen im haus alles klar
die polin box sie sich die boxen sich
versuche reinzugehen abgestimmt oder ok
jetzt hat er gut kann ein weg gewollt
wird aber das genick
ok 30 schüler sich verbrennt
okay da muss ich muss ich muss ich muss
mich lustig und ich hab jetzt schon ein
logo gehängt
leider kommt wieder einer rein der
gleiche nochmal alles klar wir haben wer
mit weggehauen aber er weiß natürlich
dass wenn es haben das ist die frage
kommen wir da jetzt wieder rein dem
abstauben back zurück das ist gut für
uns denn papa kommt ja wohl günstig hier
auch noch oder als ob nicht als auch
nicht allzu viel macht
ach du scheiße okay aber ja okay sind
wieder dunkel herausstelle raus ich mach
hier nicht in damit ich weiß ja nicht
mit vielleicht kann man sich im haus
versteht alles klar
und gold apfel ist am start und jetzt
ist ja ok den kontinent nicht politik
wird ja wohl und nicht das doch indirekt
wieder kommt erstmal tür zumachen
gut gut gut gut noch mehr stars ist die
gold zwar noch anziehen hier für die
fashion faces alter es gold gießen fake
alter bastelt wollen jetzt hier olala
menge fahrer aus zwölf stück sauber
sauber
ok nein da kann man die glocken läuten
die glocken
warum auch immer das geklappt hat ich
weiß es nicht das glück ist uns heute
holt und jetzt könnte man diese tür zur
wache alter wir werden alter wie viele
leute in diesem treppenhaus schon
gestorben sind
wenn ihr euch dazu gekommen diese
reallife geschichte zu erzählen wollte
gms dafür leute draußen
ok theoretisch wer hier reinkommt können
wir uns den gold apfel droppen dann eher
sind sein gesicht und hoffen dass wir
damit wecken können und nein trotz gold
abfahrt der alter schwede
okay das ist okay ich leute ich glaube
mein letztes stündlein hat geschlagen
was ich noch sagen wollte ich habe
momentan montag sport dienstag ist mein
einziger freier tag mittwoch habe ich
sport und donnerstag live stream freitag
sport samstag live stream und
sonntagabend auch einen festen termin
jeden sonntag und ja das ist das
momentan eine woche nach dem ausbruch
jetzt wird gebaut wenn ich hab noch
einen ein ass in der tasche ein ass im
ärmel
naja ok er denkt denkt kann was mit dem
bau motto gab es nochmals richtig kehrte
auch hatte die fei jetzt aufgesammelt
frage ja toll was die wahl doch einmal
hinter uns der im speed ex alte com
ja okay leute aber nie live geschichte
noch zu komplettieren ich habe dazu noch
montag vorliegt und dienstag vorlesung
und donnerstag vorlesung also mittags
und vormittags von morgens und dazu noch
jeden tag videos das war es von der
heutigen challenge
danke für den vorschlag den fast zehn
kids gemacht im deathmatch und ansonsten
war es soweit von heute haut rein und
macht's gut